this White House is a total joke and a
farce and an embarrassment to us all
which is evidenced by that image of uh
you know the White House Press briefing
and the cast of Ted lasso is standing in
the background and a white with
everything going on in the world that
even this white house I mean they tell
us all the time it's we're facing uh a
crisis from all these different
directions the world's about to end
because of climate change Russia is on
the verge of taking over the world I
mean this is what they tell us and you
have time
to bring in the cast of Ted lasso at the
White House and they're there to
advocate for mental health why would why
are they experts on mental because they
make a TV show they make a feel-good TV
show and so that makes them experts on
Mental Health I mean these are the
people they're all about credentialism
usually well what are your credentials
where did you go to school to become an
expert in this and then they turned to
the cast of Ted lasso to be mental
health experts at the White House